all right Cody is with us in Rapid City
South Dakota hi Cody how are you hey
how's it going better than I deserve
what's up yes well I am 24 years old my
just got engaged Saturday ngratulations
yeah thank you sir thank you yeah she's
a beautiful lady and I love her to death
biggest thing I'm having a problem with
right now is I'm just living week to
week with paychecks and I've been doing
that for last eight years and I'm just
fed up with it you know I want to get a
little nest egg just in case you know
something goes wrong with the vehicle or
the house like my apartment or you know
or just a rainy day fund kind of thing
and I can't seem to keep myself on the
right straight track and narrow if I
figured I call somebody that has some
background with that oh well there's
something about putting a ring on a
woman's fingers it makes you grow up
about five notches doesn't it yeah life
life suddenly got serious yeah I did
yeah that's what I mean yeah I know I
didn't mean to insult you but as but
it's not already mature before but I'm
just saying the other one dude I'll go
ahead and warn you ahead of time other
ones when you have a baby you go just
like it's super responsible all of a
sudden so all right
very cool what do you do for a living
I'm actually I work for a major fittings
pipe fittings and pipe company Northwest
pipe by the rapid we do they've been
very high local delivery I Drive truck
for them make deliveries and uh come
back and load up again and go back out
again and what are you making here uh
right around 15,000 a year so okay and
are you working 40 hours yeah 40 we can
work a little more we get around to it
but right around basically 40 hours okay
so if a family of two or a family of
three lives on $15,000 a year that's
below the poverty level that yeah so
what that tells us is is you need a
career track that gets you out of that
truck yeah not today but when you're 29
I don't want you driving that truck
still agreed yeah you got to be making
more money in this so so what is your
plan on that what's your career plan uh
well I have I have potential to expand
I'm here to become better and get
further along mm-hmm
and like I said I'm alive only been with
the company maybe 60 to 90 days I just
got the package and so I got my dental
and vision but I couldn't afford the
hell so okay all right um so you're
heading the right direction then you got
you got your foot in the door and you
got a plan to move out of the truck into
other things that that company does yeah
I would like to expand here yeah they're
great company they've helped me out
numerous times so when I meet you in
your 39 15 years from now what are you
going to be doing with your life
hopefully with a happy family and no I'm
not about of earn income what's your
career oh well I buy trade I'm a welder
is that what you won't be doing when
you're 39 I'd like to be on my own
business I've always thought I could be
that way and I've always had leadership
skills and stuff doing what you want
what you want your business to do I want
to be able to design something and have
it come reality but you know I mean like
kind of an engineering I guess you could
say okay but the reason I'm asking you
all these questions is is it solves the
problem that you called me about because
you've got to have something that you're
aiming at and you need to you need
you've spent a little time dreaming I
want you to start dreaming again and
thinking about okay when I'm 40 years
old this is exactly who I want to be
able to be owning a business and I'm
doing this this this and this and and
then you start thinking about that and
you go okay what's what have I got to do
to get there
well I got to get some training in this
I may have to take a class or two in
that I'm going to have to work for this
company for awhile and and learn some
things while I'm here and move up while
I'm here but if you do not have
something with your career that you're
aiming at you will stall out and your
income will never increase does that
make sense
yep kind of where I'm at now yeah
because part well no you just been there
90 days you're not exactly stalled out
well I mean I've sort of been doing for
most amount I mean when I was in college
I was going for computers and I kind of
dropped out of that you weren't aiming
at something you were just wandering
yeah you can't do ready fire aim
have to do ready aim fire okay so I want
you to look down the barrel that gun I
want you to sight it on something and I
want you to have that target identify
that bull's eye and then begin to pull
the trigger everyday to where when
you're 40 years old you're going to be
doing X Y Z and you have laid it out and
you know you might get there sooner but
you know what are the steps I've got to
take in my life to become one of those
okay and it needs to be very detailed
very clearly painted to where you're
you're as Chris Hogan says your dreams
are in HD now in the meantime we're
going to get your money act together
with the money you do have and that's
getting you on a monthly budget clearing
up any debt you've got building up your
emergency fund and some of that just
involves staying home at night instead
of going out yeah there's been a lot of
money going out at night yeah okay
well it's not like it's not like going
out to the bars it's more like going out
just driving around and you know getting
today after day's work you just want to
kind of go out and have fun and do
something that's hard to do nowadays
especially with right to the gaff and
everything and you just got to be
careful because it's your spending money
that you don't have so we got to get you
under control there so I'm going to give
you guys a wedding gift it's called
Financial Peace University it's our nine
week class on how to handle money and I
want the two of you to go through it as
part of your engagement process together
and it's going to change your life dude
and I'm also going to send you a book
called start and that's the book that
helps you get where you want to go when
you're 40 so you hold on we're gonna get
you started man this is the Dave Ramsey
show